peu
[Musique]
pour livrer le bois vous utilisez
toujours ce petit château plus
maintenant
cette taxe dans sa série en cours
maintenant c'est fini
combien de poire de tout remettre dans
le charbon au maximum 500 kg largement
c'est un métier très dur pour monter
aussi
je gardais ya combien d'années que vous
livrez du bois et du charbon à paris
depuis 1946 et auparavant rejeté ou dans
l'autre vous êtes originaire du lot
et quel métier faisiez-vous le sénateur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi est ce que le commerce du bois
et charbon est toujours tenue par des
bougnats ce que vous savez ça on va
fâcher antonelli les gens venaient
vendre leur charbon se réparer il a mené
avec kitten enfin quoi
c'est là que l'idée leur est venue
d'ouvrir un café charbon quoi va en même
temps que le chameau les algériens
étaient allés porter l'eau il y avait un
long terme et appelé sa mère
maintenant on se passe très bien pour
nous mais ce qui est beaucoup de gens
qui vivent du charbon et du bois dans ce
quartier ce qui a beaucoup de bunia oui
ça disparaît de plus en plus il a
récemment quelques-uns de ceux qui
restent et travail accord était en fait
une chose mais l'hiver encore libre
comme en nos chances
il ya des personnes âgées qui habitent
un état va changer de ce chantage au
foyer le monde
[Musique]
tout le quartier sera reconstruit ce qui
arrivera peut-être un jour on aura plus
besoin de bunia vous croyez que c'est un
métier qui va mourir je pense je pense
il s'enferme de plus en plus c'est
dommage c'était oui quand je suis arrivé
j'étais en pleine force ça me plaisait
ça très bien
aucun regret si je le regrette
le métier oui ce serait à refaire vous
le referiez le même forêt et et vous
madame n'aimait pas ce métier qu'est ce
que vous lui reprochez c'est dur quand
il faut s'occuper des enfants de du
commerce est tout à la fois c'est très
dur pour une femme m'ont un peu ce clap
[Musique]